no pictures I don't know who would you
are going to record obviously at this
time I'm thrilled to welcome the cash to
kill your darlings Dane DeHaan and
directly michael c hall there is it's
like their paint homage and giving you
this is pretty good hello i'm sheila
movies online a question for each of you
what was it that really resonated when
you read the script with your character
and was there anything that really
surprised you that you discovered about
them that you might not have known it
wasn't in the script just in a process
of research uh yeah well I mean Lucien
Carr to me was entirely a surprise I
didn't really know that he existed and I
didn't know that this story actually
happened so it was all kind of a
surprise you know he was uh he had he
has kind of this charisma and this
extroverted quality of him that I think
is different from work I've done in the
past and but still a really complicated
individual so it was you know he just
seemed like a really hard person to wrap
my mind around and that's kind of what
attracted me to him but he was a
completely new person to me as a whole I
you know reading Alan's Diaries from my
name is a teenager and you know that
combined with the character that I saw
in the script he was just somebody that
I found him very likeable immediately
you know he's seen by all accounts and
people do talk about him to have been
very kind and warm and very good company
and but also like the Diaries reveal him
and as the thought to be this kind of
really interesting mix of somebody who
had it immense confidence in their
intellect in their kind of very rich in
a life but that doesn't marry up with
what they presented to the world at that
time because he was still quite reserved
and shy as a as a young man I think I
I was very young I think that that's it
that's a very interesting split and then
a personality that's a very interesting
sort of fun your difference in whether
the difference between that kind of gain
her confidence in that outer you know
shyness of was very interesting to me
and had something that he was definitely
an interesting character regardless of
what else he went on to do in terms of
being poet he was the man that was in
the script was interesting of himself um
yeah I was aware of this story and went
through my period of fascination with
the beats and I was excited that it was
being told especially being told as as
well as it was in and John in the Austin
script and I was excited more
specifically about the opportunity to
humanize and sympathize this guy who was
sort of a footnote and a lot of accounts
of the formative years of the beat
generation and was if anything
characterized as a bit of a
two-dimensional billing stalker and so I
like that the the movie seemed to aspire
to round him out a bit I was appealing
and here's Michael were you able to do
much research on David cuz I know
obviously there's a lot out there on all
these other characters but where did you
learn about him yeah there's relatively
little but there was enough in the book
of martyrdom and artists the allen
ginsberg journals there are some
real-time accounts of his first meeting
with David cameras and it was really
helpful there was enough that I could
make informed choices as I filled in the
blanks that were there but there was
some research but
it was an unimaginative exercise too in
my question for Danielle um you being
the keys actor and love is a young man
that is that a like a point of view of
being actors you get kind of change
before like a five years ago and now um
I mean yeah I think the last of having
since finishing Potter you know there's
been a huge journey for me in this video
in just in terms of you know I'd never
worked really with different crews
before on with different groups of
actors before and and so you know coming
to after the one in black I was filmed
in England you know if you've done a
Harry Potter film you're never going to
work again in England without knowing
somebody on the kroger because they
never had so many people so it so coming
that she didn't kill your darlings was a
huge thing for me because it meant that
I just had to you know I was not going
to be working with anybody on you and
you know you find out who you are again
on the thermal surface sort of it felt
like sort of starting fresh in a way but
that was really exciting and I'm you
know working with John krokidas art
director he he did to introduce me to
techniques and ways of working that I'd
never really been trying before and it
was yeah it was very exciting so I do
think I don't know what point exactly
but I think so from doing how to succeed
the musical and through sort of kill
your darlings was that was a big period
of transition for me in terms of what
the way I worked hi Angela Dawson 40
features and I want to ask each of you
this son these beat writers and poets
they have such a staying power they've
been around 5060 years and it seems like
every generation like you said Michael
um you know relates to it in some way
and I was just wondering um you know as
when you guys were a little bit younger
in your case okay what did you have some
angsty writing and thoughts that you put
down that just
you know either kind of reflected this
kind of you know feeling that these guys
wrote about and why do you think there
is such staying power with these guys I
think we're still you know feeling the
ripple effects of the cultural
phenomenon or revolution that they that
they perhaps started and yeah I think I
think a fascination with with their work
probably does coincide with a period
when you were coming into awareness of
the ways in which whatever conventions
there are might constrain you and it
speaks to that awareness and appetite to
transcend them or break those boundaries
or chains and I definitely have some
journal entries are characterized by
ultimately dis run-on sentences trying
to emulate some of what it inspired me
yeah I definitely rub my fair share some
real bad poetry I wrote when I was about
17 or 18 yeah and I think in terms of
the in terms of the beats i think
there's something about the the way they
did what they did you know as somebody
who grew up outside the outside the
states you know it they don't have the
thing i compared to and the thing i sort
of uses my point of connection to them
is the punk movement in the 70s between
25 and 79 and it just because that's
that had the same kind of excited
nihilism to it that you know just about
tearing everything up and starting again
and and you know there's there's
something really thrilling about that
and the language usually used to say
something which i think definitely
applies to the beats about there are two
types of poets and the world there are
people who write poetically about their
lives and their people who
if poetically and write about it and
that's and that I think sums of that
kind of there's a wild abandon that goes
along with them that even if you not you
know even if you don't get every
reference revie illusion because there a
lot of poetry is incredibly dense you
can kind of get swept up in the rhythm
and the excitement of it you actually
publish no no yes um yeah also guilty of
teenage poems of trying to achieve naked
self expression um but listen I mean I
think that their effect on like today's
society is like it's kind of amazing
it's not just that the their books are
still celebrated and read but also like
they were the original hipsters and like
where I live in Williamsburg Brooklyn I
can't walk down the street without
seeing at least ten people dressed
exactly like Jack Kerouac it's really
insane um so they they you know they
obviously their books had this huge
impact but also their entire what they
stood for and how they dressed and you
know all that stuff still resonates
today maybe even even maybe even the
most now since then in terms of like
what they stood for in the impacts has
had culturally please tell me you all
saved your headphones and then we'll be
on DVD yeah well as to someone maybe
some of mine were actually I had
stability to have them published under a
fake name when I was like 17 and so yeah
they're out there they're not actually
particularly angsty once thankfully if I
remember correctly oh yeah don't don't
look them up as I nice point of saying
that now
not your pen name no I don't make it
that easy is there any difference in
playing people who are in that period
versus playing people who are
contemporary I mean do you think
differently about how they grew up or
walk differently or do anything
differently than you do playing the
contemporary character well yeah I mean
sure yes absolutely um I don't think it
it's not like terribly conscious effort
but i think you know they certainly
spoke differently and i think that the
script does a really good job of
capturing the characters individual
voices but also you know emulating the
way people would take in the 40s and you
know just having like an awareness of
what's going on around you and the
politics of the time and that kind of
thing i mean these were people that if
they expressed how they truly felt about
some things they would be criminalized
and they would go to jail so that
obviously has a deep impact on how you
act with those around you and just
having that awareness I think affects
what you're doing yeah the one is on
black thing of as well I was sort of
speaks to that it's just the moment
before and you know a date and I kiss in
the park there's to stop you don't have
an awareness that you know that what
this wouldn't just be not only is it a
big moment because he wants to get into
the first time also it does have to like
check around to see if anyone is there
so I think it does just inform choices
and stuff like that but but yet it's not
something you focus on to a dogmatic
yeah I would agree with all of that I
mean I think it's especially with the
job that our wardrobe people did and and
that and the script is so so well
rendered that a lot of it could be
unconscious like things said you know
you could just give over to living in a
world that is contextualized in a
totally different way everybody has
different things that that are useful
but whether it's listening to music or
putting on the clothes or what have you
but um yeah was there any sort of
research you did into the time serie I
know John mentioned movies like Hilda
were a big inspiration I've actually
Michael so the thing i did find very
helpful in it or was the music of the
period and just all ages but wasn't
exactly period-appropriate like there's
some stuff there that just sounds very
evocative over time period and I thumb
and also as appropriate for either
listen to a lot Joe Stafford who I'd
never come across before but I'm sort of
found found her online and like songs no
other love and you belong to me some of
that i did find as well as mike said
like the costuming and yeah me I just um
you know having awareness of what the
40s were what was happening hopefully
wish no I like to think that I do with a
question morning Brian Rojas cinema see
in the film Alan and Lucien very excited
about disrupting the established order
of just the literary movement I'm
arguably you as actors all three of you
have taken some very challenging roles
that we've seen you in I'm wondering if
you would consider yourself wanting to
challenge the system with some of these
rules Daniel maybe in this film you'll
be talked about that but as actors are
you excited about the opportunity that
you can take to challenge maybe the the
rigid more formulaic parts of the film
industry with some of these roles that
you're taking um
yeah I mean I'm not trying to I was
challenging the system quite like but
you know I don't you know I I like to
think that if the choices I make are
slightly unexpected or you know
challenging people then that is good
that you know that can't be a bad thing
I don't think um and yeah i mean i don't
i don't know if it's like in any way
raiding against the industry but I also
do think that you know we are definitely
three I think fairly like-minded people
in terms of what we value inn in scripts
and storytelling and i think i will be
kind of on the look for more challenging
material as a rule than like maybe some
bigger some other stuff you might be
thinking of done i'm certainly I'm drawn
to things that in one way or another
could be characterized as subversive
you're all kind of like minded I know
you've all been on stage oh is that
something you bonded over or you think
that the fact that you get to play
really against type on stage it's
something that you look for your film
roles um I think we all kind of did bond
over in fact that we all do theater you
know if we kind of nerd it out a little
bit yeah that was something I think we
all kind of talked about and bonded over
and talked about the musical so we've
done a place week does musicals have you
done cuz obviously no Michael is in
Chicago yeah well Justin my you know
youth um I did a lot of musicals um you
know like heist in high school in
college and you know I did all of them
right if you would know what musical to
bed Daniel will tell us his pen name oh
really did I mean like when you're a
young person in like rural America and
what you want to do is act like what's
available to you is usually musicals so
like you know I did like Annie twice I
think I did a christmas carol 12 times
daddy warbucks I one time I was dead
Warbucks and one time I was the rooster
gabba for Rama screen um I have a
question regarding the fact that all
these characters were real people and
I'm just wondering if it's a little bit
more daunting to portray someone who's a
real life person is it hard to hold back
judgment and effort rate him you know
unbiased Lee and did this is a question
for all of you did you go into did you
go into work thinking one thing and
having to come out thinking something
else is it more difficult to play
someone real as well I mean it's it's um
it's fun to have some real things to
hold on to it's a it's a it makes it to
some degree of different exercise to
play a real person and I certainly I
think whether it's purely fictional or
based on a real person
you know judgment must be withheld or
not exist in the first place if you're
going to and in the case of David camera
or and certainly didn't think of him as
a stalker I thought of him as someone
who was in love with the wrong person
and couldn't let it go yeah I definitely
think you have you do have a certain
Universal responsibility but but also
you know you know as as Michael said
it's it's fun there's a huge amount of
there's a lot more material for you to
hang on to and really go he actually did
that this happened and that is how he
responded to that event and that so you
get a real insight into somebody's
character so there's some you know
you're not starting from scratch in the
same way and you know and as long as LOL
alan is something you know out of the
three characters how we play he's
probably the easiest to as in find
empathy with or something or
compassionately he was a very you know I
found him very simplest with that there
are still moments where you know like
he's so easily manipulated by lucien
where there is a part of you that wants
to like shake him as a person because
you're reading about it but it's you
know it's it's it's fun to sort of just
give yourself over to that and yes it's
enjoyable and also the thing Tom took
the pressure off us a lot in this film
by by telling us not to really research
our characters too much past the point
that we find them in the movie so there
wasn't really a sensor in any way we
were having to live up to the the icons
that they became it was it was just that
we were you know playing them as the
people that were at this moment in low
light yeah you know Lucian's a tricky
one because I think Lucien work so hard
to make sure this story was never told
and he's to make sure nobody ever found
out about the story at least while he
was living the best he could so um so it
you know my responsibility is to honor
this person by trying to figure out
truthfully who they were at this point
of their life not necessarily how Lucien
would want himself to be portrayed in
the film but trying to actually dig to
the truth and the facts and there is
what's great about playing a real person
like they've already said is you know
there's real stuff out there like a lot
of the work is kind of already done for
you you just have to read it any of you
played real people before was this your
first time I mean excluding harry potter
obviously it's an interesting isn't
she's anything that because people there
is such that there is such a weight of
feeling behind that character this sort
of takes on reality there's own but um
but um I played yard plate rudyard
kipling's son and a TV hey sorry I'm
sorry I'm first time first time vanitha
away from the script lap com um so
there's so many emotionally and
physically intimate scenes in the film's
we all know which was the most difficult
to shoot and after shooting which one
helps you grow not only as an actor but
also you know as a person well thus it
was one thing that really stands out for
me is the scene where Lucian to tell Sal
I'd come back and find Lucian and find
it and he tells me he's leaving then
going on for Jack and that was sort of
seeing the wind done it a lot because it
was the audition scene 4 where was my
audition scene when I initially audition
Fallon and then it was seeing everybody
he was interested in volution bit so
they had done it a million times as well
and it was one of those you know you
worry about a scene that's that
intentional
having done it so many times when you
still be able to retain that same sort
of feeling and the one like when you
first read it and on the day well just
as we started seeing John kind of told
asked the crew to leave the room for our
first rehearsal and then just took me to
one corner of the room and gave me this
like goal which is slice to said like
whatever happens just don't don't let
Lou leave and and then he took you to
the other corner of the room and said
something to you I still don't know what
and then and and then like he just sort
of said to a something i'll just
improvise a scene you know from without
any lines in on it I somebody's never
really done any the Hat wasn't used to
working that way you know that was it it
should have been intimidating but it
sort of wasn't in that moment and then
within like two minutes I was like
crying you know it was have just like
very real to n it was and it was amazing
exercise and I've never really had that
experience of that very intense real
emotional experience during acting
before so if that was very very cool
thanks they would have jumped a to you
remember any of that day but i really i
don't know i mean that's always such a
tricky question for me um you know when
you're making a movie in 24 days every
day presents a whole lot of challenges
truthfully and every scene is
challenging in its own right and there's
a lot of really tough stuff in this film
that we had
do really fast you know I think John
brought up yesterday that the scene with
me and Dan on the stairs when I'm when
he's trying to convince me to stay on
the library stairs of Columbia we shot
in 12 minutes which I think could hum
you know just is I think a good example
of the challenge of this entire movie
presented um that water in the Hudson
River was pretty cold i'm surprised dane
didn't mention it because he had how
close them uh NC police just pulled up
over life what are you doing but i don't
know i mean i would agree with dana it's
really hard to single anything out but i
think just just tolerating being in a
place of such unfulfilled passion you
know that's that's a just a bit
challenging place to live and tolerate i
don't think you guys so much for being
here i think yeah i did one purpose i
would watch that Andrew bloom is awesome
Creighton screenwriting magazine I'll
lighten up with a really fun question
for you Daniel okay okay that little
adorable broom dance you did in the very
house often in Patterson was like that
was that improvised are scripted and
choreographed yeah now set the tone for
vibrancy in the movie that you know to
come did it doesn't thank you very much
that was one of those weird things wet
like the song I was doing that too was a
completely different song to the one
that will be playing in the movie so and
I knew that at the time so I was like
trying to both dance to the music and
make it non specific it was like it was
so that's where that's my that's my
nonspecific last dance that you talk
I was I was wondering if they were there
was music at all unsaid if you were just
sort of know it was the song was playing
was and and it could be like you know
that pink floyd thing they do with Dark
Side of the Moon you sync it up with
Wizard of Oz you can do this if you like
with with with this it was ain't nobody
here but us chickens by Luke Jordan if
you have the inclination one like you
can do it thank you guys so much for
your time thank you very much
you